we're really learning a ton this week
about how you can
uh lie with graphs lie with charts lie
with statistics and we're learning all
of it from from fox news earlier this
week i showed you um a completely
deceptive chart which presented the
opposite of the truth with regard to
america's healthiest and unhealthiest
cities that was earlier this week today
i'm going to show you a clip which is
really a master class in how to
deceptively use statistics
tucker carlson hosted
charlie kirk on his program charlie kirk
is sort of like a right-wing
um
indoctrinator of college kids i guess is
the way i would say it through an
organization called turning point usa
now charlie kirk has no medical
knowledge or expertise whatsoever
and he appeared on the tucker carlson
program and argued that vaccines might
increase deaths coveted vaccines might
increase deaths now before we even start
the clip i'm going to remind you that
that's not true
it's not true
but look at how they frame the data
to create that possibility okay let's
listen here so here's a shocking story
look you should care no matter what side
you're on above all about how americans
are doing and one of the main measures
of how they're doing is how long they
live if you're dying younger there's a
problem and a lot of them are dying
younger
this fact comes to us from the life
insurance companies which keep close
track of that and notice this according
to their data according to scott
davidson the ceo of one american
insurance
reported deaths in the age range by the
way no no
one america insurance doesn't have
anything to do with one american news
just just so everybody's clear
18 to 64 those the working years
were up 40
in the third quarter of last year
compared to pre-pandemic and pre-vaccine
totals now remember 18 to 64. that's an
important aspect of this
we are seeing right now the highest
death rates we have seen in the history
of this business not just at one america
40
is just unheard of and again these are
the guys who do this for a living and
they're shocked
so the question
what's causing this
it's clear our leaders don't think kovid
is to blame here's stacy abrams
masculist in front of a room full of
mass children and she has at least one
very obvious comorbidity here's barack
obama masculist in the face of his
masked servants as they build his latest
mansion in hawaii
so if corona is not causing these deaths
and it's not
what is causing these deaths 40 percent
increase
charlie kirk is the co-founder of
turning point usa to sort of piece on
this
first of all why on earth would you have
charlie kirk on to talk about this it
makes no sense at all we learned about
it he joins us tonight
to assess charlie kirk thanks so much
for coming on what is this thank you
we don't know i mean the one business
that actually tells the truth regarding
the death of americans is life insurance
they have to get this right they have
entire teams of actuaries that study
this data all day long it's not the
public health authorities that are
warning this it's a single ceo of a
major life insurance company says hey by
the way there's kind of a 40 increase in
death 10 he said would be a once in 200
year catastrophe we have a 40 increase
in death and it's not because of covet
and we deserve answers and what's so
amazing tucker is that we've known this
information and this data for a couple
weeks now
where are the politicians where are the
leaders where the people we put in
charge to actually care about the
well-being of our people well at least
we know how many times joe rogan used a
bad word in a podcast the last 10 years
i guess we're getting our pronouns right
for our six-year-olds but we have a 40
increase in death amongst the supposed
healthiest portion of the american
population this is a catastrophe we
deserve answers and some would
conjecture hey does this have something
to do with the fact that we might have
done a mass inoculation strategy we know
that there was deaths of alienation
suicide and otherwise but there's no
answers no one's talking about it
so i mean isn't this the primary number
they should be focused on if you're in
charge of the well-being of the american
people and the death rate jumps by 40
in a cohort
you know that's not supposed to die
young
then like why aren't you hair on fire
upset about it i i'm honestly confused
well it's it's either they don't care or
they don't know how to talk about it or
they are too concerned about gdp numbers
or stock market increases or immigration
quotas or whatever it's a mass casualty
event it's that simple and the fact that
the insurance company so listen this
this is really
a master class
in deceptive use of
um of statistics so so you really have
to break this down in parts
kovidvac he talks about the mass
inoculation campaign maybe it's
something we need to look at here
covet vaccines protect you from covet
death they're very very good at that
but they say well
vaccines happened
and deaths went up
what's going on maybe the vaccines are
part of this
you have to critically analyze the
primary sources and when you do you
realize that this has been studied
extensively first of all it is the right
that loves to say
a lot of the people that supposedly died
of kovid didn't really die of covid they
died of something else now you and i
have already discussed well
um kovid can cause someone to die
due to some intervening or intermediate
condition
covid in many of the people that die
triggers
a separate illness that eventually leads
to death uh it can cause cardiac issues
it can cause respiratory issues it can
all sorts of different things they are
the ones who were telling us a lot of
the people supposedly dying of cove that
aren't really dying of covet they're
dying about other stuff
here the some of those people are in
these statistics some of these people
are the people that the right wingers
have been saying they shouldn't be
classifying as dying of coven because
they're actually technically dying of
other stuff well that's what you're
seeing in the data when they say even
not counting covet you see these people
dying
it's the people you've been talking
about that didn't quote really die of
covet that's one piece of this
second piece of this we know
that due to two things one for a while
all non-emergency care being delayed in
the health care system and number two
because a lot of people say i don't want
to go to a medical facility right now
i've got that ache i've got that symptom
i don't i'm gonna delay this screening
or that that screening we know that
conditions for example like cancer are
on average being diagnosed later when
you diagnose cancer later
the
treatment options are more limited
they're less likely to be effective and
your death rate is going to be up so
that's also a real thing here and the
irresponsibility of saying i don't know
the mass inoculation campaign we got to
be thinking about it is not only
irresponsible
uh but i think they even know that it's
not true i don't think there's any way
charlie kirk i don't know
but tucker carlson there's no way tucker
carlson thinks that the reason the death
rate is up is because of vaccination
there's just no way and they're jumping
around it's not even they're jumping
three steps ahead they're just jumping
three steps in any direction and
connecting things for which there are
not actually connections and it's
irresponsible and it's part of the
continued disinformation that is being
spread on fox news
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20
off monk packs keto nut and seed bars
which taste just like your favorite
sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance
monk pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout